across series galaxies and generations
one question has been left fairly
open-ended in the Star Trek franchise
after over a half Century's worth of
series and films we may finally have an
answer star fleet has its fair share of
Heroes but unfortunately few Amber Rose
fall into that category achieving a high
rank in the Federation might be a major
award for The Intergalactic explorers
but the price of having such a powerful
role has corrupted more than one leader
viewers have long argued about these
leaders and their various levels of
failure with the popularity of Star Trek
Picard's seemingly reinvigorating the
franchise it only makes sense that the
discussion is popping up once again many
have questioned what causes amarals to
go bad and this discourse has opened up
a theory that has long followed the
franchise across various series after
the original series its follow-up Star
Trek the Next Generation and Star Trek
Deep Space Nine began to explore the
darker side of power using Amber Rose as
a catalyst for some pretty bleak
plotlines in Star attract the Next
Generation in particular it seems that
the Amber rules are really only there to
bother crew members specifically
captains despite Picard's loyal service
to Starfleet they constantly question
the captain's choices for someone who
has been entrusted to run the Enterprise
is surprising how little fate star
fleet's leaders have in him it's hard to
overlook the drum head when bringing up
questionable Admirals or a dilithium
chamber explosion leads to accusations
of sabotage in response to retired
Amaral Nora Sati heads up an
investigation on the Enterprise the crew
discovers it was not a deliberate act
but Sati refuses to stop her Pursuit her
eventual questioning of even Picard
himself leads to a tribunal and the
entire storyline exposes a fear hatred
and paranoia that continues to be
relevant in today's society seeing Sati
confronted with the words of her father
provides a powerful rebuttal to such a
low sum qualities and shows how
important it is to stop them first
speech censured the first thought
forbidden First Freedom denied chains us
all irrevocably in turn Deep Space Nine
offered Admiral Ross whose motives have
led to healthy debates among fans one
reddits her praise for us for not
occupying the archetypal quote Starfleet
of bammarole role in the series While
others were able to identify acts like
allying himself to the morally ambiguous
section 31 as fairly destructive even if
it benefited Starfleet the Star Trek
franchise crossed over into adult
animation with the series Star Trek
lower decks it follows crew members of
the ship ceratos giving them an
unprecedented active voice in many
live-action series these characters
would have been relegated to the
background or completely unseen in many
cases providing a unique perspective on
Starfleet goings-on tackling overlooked
details also gave the series a chance to
reflect on why amarals often turn bad in
one episode vice admiral buen Amigo even
talks about reaching the coveted level
and demystifies its importance according
to him the lack of a reason to push
forward sends seemingly ethical leaders
on the wrong path start
once you're in Admiral you hit a wall
I've been trying for is to make a name
for myself it doesn't hurt that Star
Trek has often explored the idea of
amarals gone bad a season 3 finale of
lower decks featured one Amigo coming to
terms with his own decisions an idea of
AI in place of the Starfleet crew may
have seemed like a good idea to win
Amigo at one point but it soon proved to
be a deadly decision much like Picard
and Amaro Sati the choice of efficiency
over actual crew experience and empathy
touches on an unfortunate pattern higher
ranking officials demeaning or
overlooking the contributions of lower
ranked star Fleet members
foreign